JORDAN, MEADOWS, GATES,
DEVIN NUNES, I CAN'T MENTION
THEM ALL, RADCLIFFE.
HERE WITH REACTION FORMER HOUSE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN,
FORMER STATE AND FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR, NEVER LOST A CASE
PROSECUTOR, FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
TREY GOWDY IS WITH US.
ALL RIGHT, YOU WATCH THIS.
I THINK I KNOW THE FEDERAL RULES
OF EVIDENCE, CORRECT ME,
COUNSELOR, IF I'M WRONG HERE BUT
THEY DON'T ALLOW HEARSAY
WITNESSES, AND SHORT OF AN
EXPERT WITNESS OR TWO, I ASSUME
OPINION WITNESSES WILL NOT BE
WARRANTED IN A SENATE TRIAL
PROVIDED OVER BY THE CHIEF
JUSTICE OF THE SUPREME COURT.
>> YEAH, I DON'T THINK THE
SENATORS CARE ABOUT THE LAW
PROFESSORS TO THE EXTENT THEY
CAN STAY AWAKE WHILE THREE LAW
PROFESSORS TESTIFY.
I DON'T THINK THEY CARE ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT THOSE THREE LAW
PROFESSORS THINK THIS PRESIDENT
SHOULD BE REMOVED FROM OFFICE.
HEARSAY OR NEARLY IS NOT
ADMISSIBLE.
THERE ARE CERTAIN EXCEPTIONS.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT A JUST THE
OTHER NIGHT ON THE PHONE.
YOU CAN GET CERTAIN HEARSAY IN.
BUT THE RECORD IS ALREADY
COMPLETE.
THEY'VE CALLED ALL THEIR
WITNESSES.
IRONIC ENOUGH, THE HOUSE
JUDICIARY DIDN'T CALL A SINGLE
SOLITARY FACT WITNESS.
THEY CALLED MORE FACT WITNESSES
FOR THE WATERGATE IMPEACHMENT
THAN THEY DID FOR THE TRUMP
IMPEACHMENT.
THE RECORD IS ALREADY AND, IT'S
FULL.
LET'S VOTE.
SEND IT TO THE JURY AND LET'S
VOTE.
>> Sean: I ACTUALLY COULD BE
PERSUADED EITHER WAY IN THAT I
ACTUALLY THINK THESE PEOPLE ARE
SO NUTS THAT, LET THE HOUSE
REPRESENTATIVE, WHOEVER THEY
APPOINT, LET THEM DO WHATEVER
THEY WANT TO DO.
THEN ONCE THEY HAVE THE VOTES,
THE 51 VOTES I WOULD ASSUME,
CALL THE ROLL, GET IT OUT OF
THERE.
BUT THEN INVESTIGATE THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
THEN THE CONGENITAL LIAR
SCHIFF.
THEN HUNTER AND JOE.
WE REALLY CARE ABOUT WITS AND
PROSES," THAN JOE IS RIGHT THERE
>> I TELL CLIENTS, YOU CAN SAY
WHATEVER YOU WANT AFTER THE
TRIAL.
YOU WANT TO SAY SOMETHING ABOUT
THE JUDGE, THE POLICE, YOU WANT
TO SAY SOMETHING ABOUT ANYONE,
BUT WAIT UNTIL THE VERDICT IS
IN.
THE PRESIDENT IS NOT GOING TO BE
REMOVED FROM OFFICE OR CONVICTED
ON THESE ARTICLES, SO MY ADVICE
ADVICES GET EQUATED AND THEN YOU
CAN SAY WHATEVER YOU WANT TO THE
DEMOCRATS AND THE MEDIA.
AS IF THEY ARE TWO DIFFERENT
THINGS.
>> Sean: DO YOU BELIEVE HUNTER
AND JOE, QUID PRO QUO JOE, AND
THE CONGENITAL LIAR SCHIFF, THE
CONTACT THAT HIS OFFICE LIKELY
HAD WITH THE WHISTLE-BLOWER,
NONWHISTLE-BLOWER, HEARSAY
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
WHISTLE-BLOWER,
NONWHISTLE-BLOWER.
THEY SHOULD ALL BE INVESTIGATED
AND THERE ARE OTHER MEANS OF
DOING THAT SHORT OF THE
IMPEACHMENT TRIAL CONFINES.
>> I CAN'T THINK OF A WORSE WAY
TO INVESTIGATE SOMETHING THAN TO
HAVE CONGRESS DO IT.
THE HOUSE HAS AN ETHICS
COMMITTEE.
IF THEY WANT TO BRING ADAM UP
FOR THAT RIDICULOUS PARODY --
>> Sean: HE MIGHT HAVE
IMMUNITY BUT HIS STAFF WOULDN'T.
>> YEAH, I MEAN QUITE CANDIDLY,
I DON'T SEE LINDSAY DOING THAT.
IF THERE ARE MISREPRESENTATIONS
MADE, WELL, YOU'VE TALKED TO HIM
MORE RECENTLY THAN I HAVE, BUT I
THINK ONCE THE PRESIDENT IS
FOUND NOT GUILTY, ACQUITTED, THE
ATTENTION TURNS TO 2020 AND THEP
ATTENTION TURNS TO 2020 AND THEE
ATTENTION TURNS TO 2020 AND THEI
ATTENTION TURNS TO 2020 AND THET
ATTENTION TURNS TO 2020 AND THEH
ATTENTION TURNS TO 2020 AND THES
ATTENTION TURNS TO 2020 AND THET
ATTENTION TURNS TO 2020 AND THEE
ATTENTION TURNS TO 2020 AND THEB
ATTENTION TURNS TO 2020 AND THEG
ATTENTION TURNS TO 2020 AND THEE
ATTENTION TURNS TO 2020 AND THET
BULLY PULPIT IN THE WORLD.
IF HE WANTS TO MAKE A POINT,
MAKE IT, BUT MAKE IT AS SOMEONE
WHO HAS BEEN ACQUITTED ON TWO
ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU ONE
MORE THING --
>> WE ARE GOING TO WIN RIGHT
NOW.
DON'T MESS IT UP.
>> Sean: I AGREE WITH THAT.
LAST QUESTION.
YOU HEAR JOE BIDEN SAYING,
YOU'RE NOT GETTING THE BILLION
DOLLARS UNLESS YOU FIRE THE
PROSECUTOR.
HE KNEW THAT THE PROSECUTOR HE
WANTED TO FIRE WAS INVESTIGATING
HIS ZERO EXPERIENCE SON THAT IS
GETTING PAID MILLIONS.
THAT SOUND LIKE A POTENTIAL
CRIME TO YOU, SIR?
>> I WOULD NEED TO KNOW MORE
ABOUT IT.
BUT I WOULD ALSO TELL YOU THIS,
I HAVE A TON OF CONFIDENCE IN
BILL BARR AND IF THERE IS A
FACTUAL PREDICATE AND WHAT WE
LEARN FROM HORWITZ IS THAT
FACTUAL PREDICATE DOESN'T HAVE
TO BE TOO HIGH TO INVESTIGATE
SOMETHING.
IF THERE IS A FACTUAL PREDICATE,
LET THE PROFESSIONALS DO IT.
I JUST DON'T THINK CONGRESS HAS
ACQUITTED ITSELF WELL SINCE I'VE
BEEN FOLLOWING IT WHEN IT COMES
TO SERIOUSLY INVESTIGATING --
LET THE PROFESSIONALS DO IT IF
THERE IS A PREDICATE FOR DOING
SO.
>> Sean: BY THE WAY, I KNOW
FOR A SHORT TIME YOU WEREN'T A
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
I AM ADVOCATING THE FULL,
COMPLETE REINSTATEMENT AT A
RAISE FOR YOU.